Silvia Broder s'en is hurrying to meet
her sister Kirsten they live in the same
village
but Silvia lives in Germany and her
sister in Denmark two months ago the
German Danish border crossing here was
closed dividing the village into now all
the two sisters can do is meet at this
barrier kissed in Boston and her Danish
husband live on the Danish side of the
village
Silvia runs a restaurant on the German
side they often meet at the border to
exchange greetings and chat about what's
happening in the village it is important
to them many of my friends live on the
other side I don't know how they're
doing I can't see them drive over there
and visit them that hurts
my sister has two grandchildren they're
like my own grandchildren I'm like a
grandma to them and of course they want
to see me sometimes my niece meets me at
the border as well and then they stand
on the other side asking why I'm not
able to hug them so we have to explain
to them that the border is shut and that
they're not allowed to visit my home
because they're in Denmark the German
and Danish coronavirus lock down means
many friends and families in the border
region can no longer meet even though
over 20 years ago the local border post
here was dismantled and border checks
scrapped the barrier is all that's left
a reminder of long bygone days
usually Sylvia's Terrace is frequented
by mostly Danish guests the restaurant
serves hearty German fare and has a menu
in both languages but with the lockdown
Silvia was forced to close down selling
takeaway meals alone simply won't cover
her costs she is facing financial ruin
we normally have space to accommodate
120 guests but with the social
distancing we will only be allowed forty
or forty four people fancy feel fancy
hue our design will try to get back to
normal when we're allowed to reopen and
the border is opened again if that
doesn't work out we'll have to close for
good after how many years we've been a
family business from 95 years we've run
it for 29
local farmers like yen's Hansen are
concerned about the situation - he grows
crops on both sides of the border he can
no longer take the direct route to his
200 hectares of land on the Danish side
he's got a special permit for designated
border crossings but that means he has
to take major detours we're very worried
these measures will stay in place until
harvest season that would mean
transporting large farming equipment and
machines but combine harvesters back and
forth along with the harvest what a
nightmare nobody knows when the border
will be reopened
[Music]
at least the members of this German
Danish band are keeping their spirits up
every Saturday they meet at the border
to play
to rehearse as they say and to send a
message that Europe needs open borders
and to highlight the importance of good
relations between Germany and Denmark in
spite of the border closure Silvia
Broder s'en shares the sentiment she
says even though the coronavirus
lockdown is making life in the border
region difficult for Germans and Danes
villagers now feel more connected than
ever in Corona cannot prevent that